we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is our caller who calls in
regularly juan
who he seems to be taking issue with
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
listen to this hey david it's juan here
i want to present the case against
double-blind placebo-controlled
and
systematically reviewed trials
so i don't know much about this but uh
okay so that would be the first red flag
i don't know much about this but let's
listen anyway my best
so if they conduct a trial and
only ten
percent of the subjects
in the trial
benefit
from
the treatment the whatever
they're going to consider
the trial to not really be
any good i mean
so that's not necessarily true what when
you're
assessing the success the effectiveness
the efficacy of a treatment or drug
you want to
compare
the effectiveness to
the best available treatment and also
have a placebo arm so and it should be
double blind so what you're looking to
do is as follows imagine that you have
some condition let's call it
you know
uh
trump syndrome for lack of a better term
you've got trump syndrome and you have a
pill
that improves symptoms in 10 of people
great
that's the best treatment we have so you
design a test
in which you take some people
and you give them the pill that's
already on the market and you take some
people and you give them a placebo and
you take some people and you give them
the new pill now some would argue you
don't even in this case you don't even
really need the placebo because the
whole point is to compare to the
approved treatment but you could you
could do it this way
the people shouldn't know who's getting
what the patient shouldn't know am i
getting the approved pill
a new pill or the placebo because
knowledge of what they're getting could
affect the results
the people treating them shouldn't know
what they're getting either so that that
would not uh influence the results and
then you compare now imagine
if the approved
pill
works 10 of the time
and the placebo works 10 percent of the
time
and the new pill works 40 percent of the
time that now becomes significant so
there's no hard and fast numbers really
the way juan is saying here percent
of efficacy yeah you know
pretty bad you normally want more than
that right you want at least greater
than 50
well the reason i think that that's the
bad logic is as follows
if you were to run that experiment
for every person in the united states
and 10 percent of the population
benefited
that is about
134
000 people
is my math right there okay the math is
the math is way off so there's 330
million people in the u.s so 10 would be
33 million not 134 000. but that's also
pretty pretty uh irrelevant because
we're not dealing with most conditions
we're not dealing with a population base
that is the entire country so this is
very confused here juan i would do a
rethink on this okay there's a reason
that the double-blind placebo-controlled
trial is the gold standard and i would
rethink this all right on the bonus show
today we will talk about
the vote from twitter shareholders on
the elon musk twitter takeout takeover
we will talk about the founder of
patagonia donating the entire company to
fight climate change and yes we will
talk about the latest r kelly conviction
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com